oh god i see an emt in a gurney guys
we're gonna kill people
well we're not gonna kill people i know
we're a hundred percent gonna kill
people
oh what a what a blaze oh that is quite
a blaze
we gotta do the tutorial first and a
single player and then it's multiplayer
hold on
i'll get you i'm coming
i'll take your haligan dude get that
halligan dude i'm getting it
the music is legit oh my god he's dead
it's funny because he seems dead but
then he starts talking to you
oh never mind just [ __ ] spied oh look
at the fire's blazing
so i wonder if this is supposed to be a
serious take on firefighting because
remember the farming was pretty serious
but we still arranged to ruin it i
wonder how we're gonna ruin this
this is not doing a lot gotta be honest
is this what real fire fighting's like
unsuccessful are you on the hose yet
mark yeah i just got on the hose
i'm i'm spraying a grease fire with some
spit from my mouth as far as i can tell
oh
it's doing something for me are you
shooting the little fire icons
oh are you supposed to shoot those yeah
uh
whoa i'm in the fire fine i broke my leg
this poor guy
oh you're actually listening to him oh
i'm getting success
i'm i'm smelling success mark yeah you
got your hot tip on shooting the fire
icons you're a goddamn genius thanks man
man this fire though
keeps fire oh my genius shouldn't the
ambulance guy with the the
gurney i think it's called gurney
shouldn't they have come like to get the
guy like
closer to the house you don't want to
get that house is on
fire you want the you want the paramedic
to get in there you know in case there's
something wrong
in case there's something wrong there's
a fire that's what's wrong there's
definitely something wrong the fire is
what's wrong
oh yeah i guess so i'm just carrying
it's just talking nonsense like a crazy
non-fire believer
is this is why this is why i played
games i don't know how to fire denier
fire's not real man it's a [ __ ] myth
don't live in fear
of fire big water just wants you here
water wants you to hide in your pool
drenched in their product fearing for
your life
that that fire can hurt you and your
family when we all know it can how are
you going to build up an immunity to
fire if you don't expose yourself
to fire yeah if everyone just agrees
to to believe the truth that fire is not
real
it can't kill us all it can't kill us
all it's called
herd fire immunity it's called
herd this is anti-flammability
yeah oh my god i did it i'm the best
this garage is not
never mind i didn't do it the fire is
above me holy [ __ ] i'm gonna die okay
it's fine
well i even have firefighters so we just
accept people are gonna die
yeah yeah but the death rate for fire
is so low everybody's got anti-flammable
insulation in their houses already what
are you afraid of
dude stop saying the truth so hard
people can't accept it
that's the problem people aren't
criticizing me because i'm insane
people are criticizing me because they
can't handle the truth
exactly happening yes
i'm fine i'm standing i'm saying oh
debriefing
dude ooh i got a chief
the garage is still on fire you said it
was out it is on uh ooh
my garage is definitely still burning oh
you could change your avatar objective
complete the zoom out
[Music]
oh good job we're done here ball is
packing up
dude we're taking the rosenbauer tp3
out oh [ __ ]
hopefully bill does a lot of the heavy
lifting
okay bob you drive bill will run
everything else
we're starting baby i don't know what's
happening
no training right out the door they need
firefighters on the ground
we've been trained you open the door
carry the dead person to the ambulance
right the ambulance to the hand to the
ambulance more like it
and then you just hose it down
individual loading bar so we know where
everyone's at that's amazing
this game consider it wow where's bill
dude bill bill where's he at who are we
all driving
i'm driving oh i'm driving wow there you
go good i think you follow the other
firefight
well there's a gps on the bottom there's
a gps right there
well i don't see that i just see a weird
yin and yang of red don't worry i got
this
dispatch all units holy [ __ ] this does
not drive like a fire truck
what do you know what a fire truck
drives like actually i shouldn't
question i'm sorry about it
[ __ ] oh we went in the ground
we're gonna need another fire truck
there apparently
the traffic accident is going to cost us
that's my bad that's not bad do we get
paid
like from this oh not anymore headlights
oh siren
oh that's helpful kind of well that
person they're not getting over they're
just slowing down
oh i can drive in first person hell yeah
marker do you just see the weird like
red and black
no i'm third screen i'm third person
what are you looking at
if you hit you can first person oh yeah
oh don't do that oh wow
the home crafting screen what is this
phone crafting what are you doing
what are you doing back there got a
weird perspective
we're gonna go stealth boys we're to go
stealth turn the emergency lights off
yeah you don't you don't want the fire
to be prepared
you want to sneak up on the fire yeah
yeah exactly by surprise
yeah yeah you know so much about
firefighting
still bob why are we so far from it yeah
why are we so far away
is this what normal firefighters have to
do to get to a fire the whole place is
going to burn down
well we were eating mcdonald's get out
of here
apparently 61 is top speed i'm trying to
hammer it boys
good driving there bob really good stuff
this is why you hired me
yeah i really like that this game has
integrated steering wheel settings
i feel like i should get my steering
wheel set up so i can be our wheel man
you could get a whole like driving
racing sim set up with like moving chair
and screen just to be a farmer
it's fine it's fine kicked out
what i don't know did you oh yep sure
did can i rejoin you guys
uh try maybe
oh my god okay made it um i clicked
join nothing is yet happening you tell
me that we gotta go back
out and then drive all the way back here
yes all right son of a [ __ ] all right
fast
driving driving time expired what did i
bomb my hallway
what are you doing any all right we got
to do that over again because you didn't
get the fast driving
to get another chance at uh yeah yeah
fast driving time
make sure you got plenty of practice
look i say just screw
the other cars just freaking go for it
yeah i wish i knew what happened
whatever happened don't do it again yeah
don't do it again
really seriously well at least we got
bill back all right let's go bill
so your guys's screen doesn't have like
a red on top and a black on the bottom
and it doesn't say home crafting across
the whole thing that's like the pause
screen or something
isn't it all right i'm hammering it the
whole time
oh it's gone now what's gone now thank
god
this is what it's like to see the normal
game screen oh you had like a bug
the whole time yeah i had like a pause
screen over my thing the whole time
all right that's sirens real loud yeah
turn that off
yeah stealth mode's the way to go
whenever you're in a fire fire ambulance
we
know if you would have been here last
time also known as
ambulance i think
into oncoming traffic is the way to live
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
perfect perfect perfect that's not bad
hey
this thing handles real good the
traction like a dream
look all these [ __ ] in the tunnel
don't they know there's fires don't they
know
yeah idiots we're 3 000 meters away
jesus
isn't there a closer fire station to
this problem no
no it's just us all right we're going
bold boys oh
yeah do you get bonus points for this
god i hope so i hope it's like burnout
paradise
i don't know if it's a slow or fast
response time i feel like we're
winning i feel like we're basically i
don't know how you going fast universe
or cranking top speed of the truck in
general here
we could chuck bill out the back if we
could drop one of the hoses we probably
don't need
six hoses yeah it's only one fire right
yeah exactly
we could dump some of this water that's
in the truck we don't really need that
much
oh yeah there goes our money i don't do
this for the sake of being a good
firefighter i do this for the money
well i mean what do firefighters do it
for for the fame no
the money only one accident so far not
bad
that's a high score
[Music]
i thought after last time you would have
nailed that left but turns out
now left trigger lefts are harder that's
fair that's fair
sky is beautiful where are these
california uh
yeah obviously based on the trees i mean
we don't take those kind of trees in the
midwest
look man slight traffic accident
that's fine this is a minor three
traffic accident i think you're gonna
get the bonus
sign who even cares think you're gonna
get the speed bonus
they look at fire hey look at that
yeah dan park nice do i get out
all right where are these who are these
other firefighters get out nerds
are these are these the the north side
firefighters what's going on here that's
a pretty small fire we got here pretty
cool yeah only like half this house is
on fire just spray some water in there
who's
what's this what's everyone doing it's
like a dining room fire it's probably
intentional this does not look like an
accident all right i call dibs on
survivors
do we determine that or is that someone
else i call dibs all right enough
looking at the house can we get in the
house
how do we get the hose out we need the
hose okay i'm called dibs on survivors
oh here's a hose oh okay we got the hose
uh i'm going in i'm going in
i need a hoser i need a hubent stank
where's the hungalo where's the the uh
the
supply hose the i got the attack
i've equipped the attack hose i'm
attacking oh no i need my tool
oh we need to breach we need to breach
the windows i'm getting there
i'm reaching i'm not excused what the
hell
excuse me water's not on how do i turn
the water supply on
oh oh is that a wait can you turn the
water off fire
i found the ax circular saw foundation
water carrying out a victim it's gonna
be okay
oh [ __ ] yeah where's the nozzle you guys
putting out that fire you see me saving
something we're gonna go there we go
we're good no
we got the nozzle i've coupled i've
coupled oh yeah it's not stopped
why just need you to cool down all right
cool thank you
these windows
all right save someone nice oh wait
let's
wreck this fire firing this is anybody
still in this room we're real awkward if
you were we
oh it's coming for you teamwork yeah
could not save the entertainment system
but honestly you should probably get a
flat screen at this point anyway
do you guys have another hose is this
all the hose you got
there's hoses on the other side of the
truck but you had to connect the supply
hose and then you got
the whole thing i'm going in with a hand
extinguisher wait there's still
electrical stuff is this the cause of
the fire still causing fire yeah are we
are we supposed to turn the electrical
off is that what we're supposed to
understand with this yeah i feel like
the cause of the fire is still causing
the fire
oh yeah we oh we need to turn the power
off mark we have a new objective for you
buddy what do you mean how am i gonna
turn the power
off the switch i flip that never mind is
there like a circumstance there's a
[ __ ] chair
i just told every ai to come help us
quench this fire
okay fire yeah the fire guy there's a
dinosaur in the bathtub
the activated fuse box where's the fuse
box we activation i know i'm looking for
it i
found it oh my god i got it jesus
yeah my god it's done there you go big
baby
good one thanks i know finally oh look
at this fire going out now there's not
even a problem
yeah this extinguisher is pretty good
this is good water this is high quality
h2o
weight gain oh actually we're pretty
good yeah this is very effective water
oh well actually it's mostly my
extinguisher that's pretty good
yeah dudes damn let me close the fridge
i don't know why i was
hoping all right i climbed out the
window look it's me in front of the
house
hey wait can i make my way let me just
do a little more spring i made my way
perfectly sure hey good job everybody
wow that water really just goes for days
look at that we learned something today
that causes a fire can recause the fire
we did pretty good though i'd say we did
really we won that fire
so yeah you saved somebody's life mark
thank you i know
he did yeah he did do we got to pick a
new mat i think we got to back out and
pick a new map
no no stay stay never mind so now we're
doing batten down the hatches okay i'm
ready
another 4 000 meters why can't people
have fires closer to the firehouse
i know well you could see the smoke in
the desert oh yeah
we're going baby this does look like
california i will admit
yeah yeah you like you would no
like you would no all right you're ready
for me to rip
are really cutting into our response
time here my friend i'm just gonna sneak
right past you yeah do that
so much for our speed accomplishment
yeah our speed bonus really going under
that was a good turn right that was a
nasty sick turn
too bad our idiot companions are [ __ ]
idiots
it's wiggly oh my god yeah a little bit
these pedestrians do not know what is up
they are really really risky what if i
mow down a pedestrian
ah is that a hospital that's good to
know yeah well if i if i run someone
over that's a really great spot
we'll be sending someone to you later
or sooner
insurance money either way he was fine
the fire is still burning this time
i can't believe it's not putting itself
out it's pretty rude
you're getting good at that bob you're
getting good at those left turns i'm
really proud of you
that's should have been murder oh oh
well
it just prevented me from murdering that
person yeah i guess they don't want a
gta
yeah i think that was your right turn
wait a second okay
hang on yeah fine you're clear you're
good you're good you're good on this
side pop a quick three-pointer there
yep you didn't even hit the bush that
was an accident-free three-point turn
what are you looking at get out of here
i don't even see a fire where's the fire
all right why is that not count go on
the spot get out
okay how oh there we go
emanating from the middle of the house
we didn't even park in the right spot
this guy did so well i mean they didn't
assign
the fire's out the fire we did it
we win i i'm gonna preemptively just
break open everything all the doors and
all this stuff
just break just go around the house
breaking everything you're gonna need to
anyway might as well right you know what
you're right i'm gonna get an axe and
i'm gonna help you with that i'll go up
to top
i see a ladder there i'm gonna take
conveniently i've got it
i'm just going to walk around swinging
my axe
you do the top i'll do the bottom you
got it i don't know
that i need uh there's someone here
hello
no don't okay i dropped that tool hello
you okay oh power just went out there's
two people up here
what the is someone breaking bones out
there what is happening
i'm breaking in the door so that the
fire can get out
you're right you're right when you're
right you're right and you're
still fired i'm coming in oh my knees oh
my god did you just hop out
yep sure did why are these windows
barred like a prison cell
dude i don't know man there's someone
else in there you guys i don't know why
you're unconscious nothing seems bad up
here
yeah i think they're sleeping i think
they're weirdos and sleeping pop off the
roof is that a viable
yeah yeah definitely yeah it doesn't
hurt at all
wow wow jumping off the roof hurts me
more
than fire does oh thank god you heal
right back up my ankles are fine
yeah i told you man told you all right
let's see this fire is
very hot i'm uh it's a warm one good
man's good high
temperature oh i'm on fire i'm gonna
break open the window so there's more
air to put it out okay there we go
oh left rear oh left rear oh
they're just standing up get out of the
house grandma
oh sorry grandpa what follow me
i can't get there okay
get there boys i can't get there boss uh
follow me i really like when you
when fire touches you as a character
your guys just all
right hey can you get that fire out
weight i got a survivor that needs to
come through there
can this guy follow me through here
follow no he went back this oh this jerk
excuse me
ow ah oh god
well this is out for a moment where did
he go
where did he go where did he go anybody
see a man run by here
did you lose did you lose his mark did
you lose oh there
oh he's here i don't know where you were
i'm gonna do this downstairs room i
think
try and get this bad boy extinguished if
we could just you know
clear this path so i can get the
survivor out where's the path do you
need a competent fire
who has an axe what is happening i don't
know man
there's a lot of smoke in here all right
this room is this this room is
persinguished
well not the hallway to the front door
thank you wade thank you
thank you working on it just keep
lighting myself on fire don't mind me
we'll put out the fire i'm ascending why
are you ascending
because there's the stairs is on fire
and i assume that means the upstairs is
on fire too
because that where i is needs out you've
got wade wade's got you
wait does not got me it's not my fault
you chose a teammate who doesn't
play the game very well sorry i'm doing
my best here there's a lot of fire and
it keeps re-spreading again
well i'm gonna try to make it through
hopefully that guy doesn't get burnt too
bad
where'd he go he's gone again he jumped
out the back window
this he jumped in back through the
kitchen window
what is wrong with you oh did he get out
i mean that's what you're going for
right but but he wasn't able to get out
before
well okay wait a minute
wait good job all right come with me sir
come with me bill is still standing here
like a dingus
just want you to build your bills how do
we get bill to do stuff oh yeah
don't run man don't run just walk yeah
that's great
all right we're getting it we're getting
oh yeah look at that oh wait we're
almost to the end of the foyer
yeah should we let it spread i mean kind
of enjoyed this time together should we
oh my god it's over oh you did it good
wow hi i would like to relive this fire
with you guys again this was a pleasant
experience for me and
i just miss you all yeah it seems to
still be on fire
is anyone curious what happens if we
don't put the fire out
i think it burns down but you know i
can't say for certain
explosive hot dogs unlocked fast excuse
me
explosive hot dogs that's been a cause
of many fires in the white house
that is yeah i mean i think i i think we
all know which mission we're about to
have to do you guys want to watch some
explosive hot dogs i guess
explode yeah oh wait can we change our
trucks what's the exclamation point on
our rosenbauer i mean
oh don't know
rosenbauer walk-in rescue oh
oh look at that we've got like a blood
mobile
i like blood oh snap i can tell bill
what to help oh no i can't tell bill
what to do
okay all right well that's fine uh
everyone ready
mark you ready to watch a fire um
burn down a hot dog stand
where are we going next boys explosive
hot dogs in our new rosenbauer blood
machine
oh bloody wheel yeah baby we got the
blood mobile
oh it is a blood mobile how is this
going to put out any fire
don't ask questions obviously you
haven't received proper training excuse
me you're right sorry boss
sorry boss you're all really dick into
physics yeah i don't know if this is the
way boss
that's not what the gps says that is
what the gps says
what gps is yours looking at is yours
okay boss
i honked why didn't they drive out of my
way well now the gps has changed to take
this into consideration at least that's
good
yeah mine has always said that this is
the correct direction i don't know what
you're talking about
you're right we don't knows what we
talking about yeah that's why you're the
driver
you're the driver we're the non-drivers
we're not driving that's a fact you
can't argue
also different from what my gps called
very different
dps and gps here i'm so confused why is
your
why is your thing so different i don't
understand hey we're stupid
you smart that's the difference i mean i
agree but i just don't understand why
hey we don't either that's why we're the
passengers we're the passengers
honk so on and so forth get out of here
okay yellow line mean
hello new vehicle it's a new vehicle
everyone sorry
blood bank we'll give you some later
wait chuck a blood
bag out the window everyone we had all
right there you go here
i have some universal recipient here's
some a b positive there you go
that's good that's good that'll help
them oh
that's a poll i think they're in the
next parade we're invited to we should
toss blood bags instead of candy much
more useful
that's pretty useful actually yeah it's
fun too fun for the whole family the
kids chucking around it's great
i really wish that like the light posts
would break gta style
yeah pretty much what is on f i don't
see no fire
why are we here oh oh it's in the lob
it's a campfire oh okay
well this ain't a problem oh the hot dog
stand is on
fire are you in the spot i i guess
there we go oh no oh no
oh the humanity
he does all those commercials like you
need a log i sell the dog
come on down i'll even cook you a frog
hot dog randy
i love that one i love it yeah it hasn't
changed
nope not in 30 years looks like he was
just about to get off work he's all
dressed up to cycle home
oh wow what this what's this pov of the
sub things
came dramatic they paid the
cinematographer in this game like ten
thousand dollars per shot really milked
it out here
all right hey wade you remember the
other one the hot dog for me
is that randy's hot doggery
i love that that's a good one it's a
good one all right guys
i've got a circular saw wasn't that one
in montgomery and he didn't used to have
his hot dog standing
yeah yeah of randy's hot doggery
can be found in montgomery you know it's
really good stuff
everyone loves it guys in the interior
compartment randy are you seeing this
i don't know what that's for but it's
open i mean i could stuff randy in there
whoa we could give blood or take it we
can take blood oh no
objective complete oh wait i thought we
were gonna not do anything
i guess i'll put randy back down i
honestly didn't expect this one to work
what do you mean a fire extinguisher you
didn't expect it to work
i could just change up equipment with
bill hold on wait mark go up to
bill see if you can swap your
person for the extinguisher nope just
nobody just took it from
i want to point out some these aren't
hot dogs these aren't hot dogs these
are not hot dogs what are these not hot
dogs
it looks like kombucha also completely
undamaged by the fire
yeah well it was a trash can i guess
whoever put something something
ruined i guess i didn't know it was
going to go out so that's all right it's
all right i'll take randy back with us
you guys okay with me dropping randy off
here he's kind of heavy too many hot
dogs
i kind of already ruined the whole point
okay all right randy there you go
incapabilizated that was really kind of
a letdown
well maybe maybe a house would be more
interesting to watch burn anyway than
that tiny little stand
okay so we'll let the whole house burn
down wade got it i
if you have anything that accelerates
the fire truck that on there i think
opening windows does right giving some
more oxygen that's a good thing for that
that's a good point
yeah that's true that's a good point
that's true so i'm only going to help
add oxygen and fuel
yes so there's wildfire park unstable
rooftop
ooh training facility
and burning news i want to do the house
i want to watch a whole ass house burn
down
yeah let's do that house oh you didn't
like the blood bag
truck it's on the list now but it won't
let me pick it it wants me to take the
tp3
oh we probably have to take one that has
yeah yeah yeah
private stupid yeah whatever i guess
we'll take the one we're supposed to
take that has the right equipment
whatever
we'll take the actual fire truck and not
chuck blood bags they
they should make a mod that's a bloodbat
gun and you shoot that at the fire
i wonder if we're gonna have to um go
through training again if we fail
horribly and let a whole house burn how
are we going to stop bill
well bill doesn't do anything bill's
kind of disgusting i can tell him what
to do i'll tell him to just do dumb
stuff
good okay oh
man a lot of body roll in this truck
yeah
this city sure does love lion statues
see a lot of them
maybe it's lion city oh good good point
what you okay sorry that was such a
close call it made me jump
okay i like how we're always unit one
these guys know how to try to treat
their top talents yeah true enough
cop wait wait girl wait
wow
[Music]
well they got a big old hose thing do we
got a big ladder hose thing
oh wait can we go up there and use that
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah call him off the ladder boys
why does unit 2 get all the good
equipment well our budget gets cut every
year
whoa
get over it give us your ladder don't
even hook that up don't even hook it up
don't even hook it up you can't you son
of a [ __ ]
we can sabotage their stuff we can
sabotage their stuff yeah we're gonna
this is our territory now
oh you put it right through my legs all
right i'm oxygenating the house
okay good good cause i'm gonna i'm gonna
steal all the attack hoses from this
truck
and go hide them places okay i'm taking
their axe and piling up their attack
hoses
in a place where they oh are you trying
to kill them i want to see if i can you
know hey
no one will know it might have been the
fire that stabbed him with an axe
what grease fire oh
put water on the grease fire yes yes
spray the water onto the grease fire
that's
oh wait hold on uh bill's fire fighting
right now oh
my god at the ceilings collapsing
that's so loud oh my god
that was really something to see dude i
wish i had like a mavic mini or
something i could fly around
oh yeah is someone fighting fire sir
bill
phil bill bills bill bill bill bill can
we turn the power on
stop that [ __ ] mark
what what what i'm walking just you
axing the [ __ ] civilians
oh you don't know who this man is it
could be horrible could be a murderer
i'm gonna waste all the water from our
truck all right bill bill can't
can't fight fire even if he wants to
good luck
idiot i wonder what happens if i burn
myself alive here and i die
wait i'm actually curious about uh
hitting this with uh
hitting the grease fire with the water i
want to see if it looks like yeah
let's go test that if it starts putting
it out
there's no water in the truck so you're
currently sol
this fire is getting kind of big i don't
think it even needs me helping it
i think we literally just broke the door
to get the hoses wait
i can i can wait the supply line's in
the back we all right we all right
let me just go ahead and prank this bad
boy
uh you're strong you just rip those
bolts off with your bare hands bare hand
baby damn that's why you're the boss all
right so do we have water now
uh maybe but that that kitchen fire is
pretty
beefy i don't know if that's necessary
oh there yeah that's good
we got this oh there's people in here oh
yeah there's
this fire it's real beefy where's the uh
where's the grease fire at
it was it you you see where all the fire
is over there it's
this [ __ ] has litter in his
garden there's a goddamn what a [ __ ]
are we are we rescuing this man yeah
you're all right sir
you're okay oh no somebody wet the bed
hey bill look at this
bill bill bill's just giving me death
glare over here
yeah bill don't look so good whoa look
how shiny this gets if i get it
that was dirty is this supposed to be
chrome oh my god this is a mirror you
need to
dust home owners yeah somebody needs to
take better care of their belongings
i think they did this to themselves look
they've got an overnight they've got
suitcases packed they were ready to go
in this fire this is insurance fraud oh
my god
i think we are getting to the bottom of
it let me show you what you've done
ow fire's hot yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna
are you setting me in the fire yeah
don't worry i'll save you oh dear don't
even revive
okay well just you and me now mark and
bill i don't feel so good
huh oh your body disappeared is that
good i'm back
what the hell you all right i know you
reincarnated
oh i was wondering about that so these
people clearly don't
don't take care of their own home i'm
going to
water their backyard yeah might as well
little pig
let me come in oh oh no
we didn't rescue the victim well i mean
did they deserve it
this was clearly insurance for us no
they wanted their world to burn
we let it burn we didn't actually check
if anyone wanted that
what do you mean no we did we did a
thorough investigation mark and i are
qualified investigators as well as
firefighters yeah we checked it out
really
yeah yeah we looked up to it you're a
driver we're investigator
okay yep so we supply hose to the
big nozzle remove that cap connect line
take that over to this oh this
oh there it is that's the thing all
right so i assume we're actually putting
it out this time
i suppose oh i've got um insurance fraud
guy
well we'll let the courts handle it i
guess we're not meant for that
disconnected electricity don't worry
about it cool
all right coming in with the second hose
sir
take this guy to the hospital but i do
volunteer to testify against him once
it's all said and done there you go very
brave of you man
very brave i know i that's what they say
about me i'm
quenching this fire just keeps kind of
growing
uh wait i have a nozzle with no with no
hose
i'm just carrying around a nozzle oh
that's
sad oh boy all right there's a grease
fire somewhere in here away just so you
know
now bob turned off the power
grease is only flammable when it's
connected to electric or something
i don't think that's i well it's
probably
really good in chemistry class i was
good at balancing equations i know what
i'm talking about
okay trust me i'm professional greece
the grease fire do we need a special
thing for it or
uh maybe a fire extinguisher instead of
the host i don't know
yeah it does did you guys not read the
briefing no no
oh okay did you yeah but i mean no
unless it's cool too then i did and if
it's not cool definitely knocked out
stupid nerd i don't even know what a
brief is what is it underwear
no because only dads wear briefs okay
yeah
so you're like a dad briefings oof
dad's gonna be cool by definition that
can't be
okay all right i'm just gonna stare into
the fire for a while as soon as you
decide to have a kid you basically sign
a contract saying i hereby declare i'm
lame
all right who's authorizing said
contract
who's the other signee you kids
everywhere
the child okay oh
you're right uh the grease fire turns
out the grease is flammable
yeah this fire doesn't seem to be on
firing itself we need do we need some
other
sort of stratagems here uh no
this is just flames yeah i told you i
eat a lot of fast food i'm very
flammable
[Applause]
okay i got most of this stuff in the
bathroom but the the roof is still a
problem
oh my god i burst into wayne help yeah
jesus i'm working on it but um yeah
apparently this is not gonna keep this
fire out
well i have a fire extinguisher why
isn't that working who's bursting into
flames
uh bob and i depending on the moment i
think that roof
is upstairs there's an upstairs no i'm
just trying to shoot the roof from
outside
but this freaking show-off up in the
ladder is just giving me the business
do we have ladders can i get a ladder so
we can like fly them up top
whoa who's shooting from the inside out
bill bill's doing some stuff oh wait
wait so wasn't there a guy is there not
a survivor we got
him already
was there a guy though do we need to get
a guy yeah there might still be a guy
if you want to take a look around there
could still be a guy i just want to know
when we get one of those helicopters
that we can dip into people's pools
oh hell yeah that's where the real
money's at i mean hella yeah
because what a lit it's a helicopter so
hello yeah
no i don't mean that how do we not have
this fire on control yet
what's all these icons the blue icons uh
i was spamming
to tell the ai to do stuff okay i'm
helping
we getting it i don't know man this
thing is like virulent
is that the right word
[Applause]
i don't know that it's actually out but
it says it is oh it's out yeah it's out
i
launching my seed into space look at me
damn that's impressive man i wish
how many keggles you do to get that we
unlock oh no those are missions
medium wait we unlocked the rosenbauer
viper
well what's the latter elevation guys we
need to use the rosenbauer viper
i don't even know what the rosenbauer
viper is we need to use that i don't
even care
okay all right that's fair enough oh i
hope it's a dodge viper with like one
fire hose in the back or some power
viper
yeah we do have a ladder the ladder
these fires are flocked
i'm sorry that wasn't that funny but
just it just hit different you know
i just imagine you like a rotund 50 year
old fire chief
steps up to the microphone and just like
ladies and gentlemen
uh wildfire to the west the city uh
scotland's a lot of problems
we got some reinforcements uh we're
gonna have helicopters tomorrow three
helicopters on the scene
and i just need to say these fires are
[ __ ] i i just need to point out that
this other truck in front of us has
somehow evolved a step further they look
like they got a better ladder than us
yeah our competition always gets the one
up in the truck
nice
maybe they should step back and let the
pros handle this yeah
stay behind me satan i like our ladder
hose i'm excited for whoever gets to use
that i'm i'm excited for you guys
i kind of want dibs on well all right
okay you can have divs
if you want dibs oh you're the boss
marky moo
you're the boss you can have it uh stop
other cars
oh my god not going to let off the gas
lining up
in the history of turns not so hot now
at least the sign broke that was
something new
why does it randomly increase my mouse
sensitivity in-game
i don't know i just thought you might we
are in the viper now that's true
all right who's ready for a spicy turn
there's there's
nothing ready there's no daddy wow too
spicy too spicy too spicy
there's no mouse sensitivity settings
there are none no there's not
the center dpi well i did i have a
button that drops it down but it's like
it only increases
all right well it's going to be very
high sensitivity on this one
can't you afford one of those like gamer
boy bath mice that has
more sensitivity i just said i do and i
drop
it lower every new map it drops it up
again
and i don't know why but it's all
twitchy now
apparently maybe you need to get a
computer that wasn't made in the 1980s
look i have a lovely alienware computer
brought to you by alienware uh-huh
that show must be nice to have a sponsor
it is nice actually
it must be great i'm sure that's really
cool it is
actually really nice and awesome it is
pretty nice that's a pretty big fire
i feel like we should stop looking at it
and spray some water on it or whatever
or where is it where's the hose i'm just
opening up some compartments
do we have hoses in the back yeah where
in the back what do you mean in the back
like in the back no oh there is a comp
oh yeah supply hose and that's a supply
house that's
one okay whoa
guys
[Music]
dude that's so sexual dude somehow your
sexual energy is really permeating
hey wait oh my god that's against tos
yeah oh wait hey yeah i would have taken
on
i'm on fire can you bash through the
window with that just like
i don't think so it doesn't seem to let
me do anything to that let me try it out
i'm gonna bash
open that window and i'm gonna see if
you can extend the ladder into the
window afterwards
i'm just gonna make the thing go as high
as humanly possible i love that about
you
mark and i'm gonna turn around and look
in three two
one wow
it's just straight up you really got a
bird's eye view though don't you
oh [ __ ] why did that give me no i just
teleported from the top
eiffel tower yeah man ct's
it's just comes with a real frenchman
fired up protecting the electricity
powers out
look at this pedestrian aren't the
police supposed to have a cordoned off
area
why are you here sir where oh dude i
could just walk up and down the ladder
when it's at a good angle like this
there's no police car here to help what
are you looking at lady get out of here
what the freaking heck am i supposed to
do ooh they got a trampoline
i don't like this anymore mad mad about
it
they got a trampoline it's literally
impossible to use the ladder because the
button
to use the hose at the top of the ladder
is the same button
that makes you get off the ladder
[Music]
how you doing oh yeah there's a person
in here does anybody want to come save
this guy
huh uh can we send bill in here on a
rescue
no i could ah guys i can't get in the
trampoline
oh he's burning alive i should probably
get him he'll see you later
all right i'm coming over did you guys
get the ladder hose working
no mark you try it do we ever figure out
if we have
noodles i found one on the ground
outside the truck that i grabbed but i
didn't find him in the truck
oh do we need to bring a hose up here
what is the deal with this
oh wait yeah can i do that can you can
you get on the ladder with a hose
i don't know it seems like there's a
hose
get off it for a second yeah yeah yeah
absolutely
there you go buddy drop hose to control
i want to climb the ladder okay you
don't need to
bring a hose with you onto the ladder ah
that's silly
oh [ __ ] i figured out how to do the
thing
how do you do that you hit c while
you're on the controls
and you switch
you switch to ejac mode all right i'm
gonna go full extendo
i love it it's really the only way now
i'm putting out
guys look i'm poning yeah i'm happening
this new
fire yeah man i still have an
unconscious person in here
but whatever at this point why haven't
you carried them out yet
uh i figured i'd fight the fire save
their house more than them
yeah property is more valuable than
human lives like what's the point of
living if they lose their house
exactly warnings are what matter that's
true you can only take with you what
isn't destroyed by fire we all know that
the saying
exactly fast mission time expired well
we're paid by the hour not by the job
so i agree yeah that's one of our
private servants
for profit fire dude for-profit
firefighting would be such a sick job
like how much more leverage could you
have in a business situation
you roll up to some family standing
outside their stupid house
and you're like all right it'll be
probably eight grand we'll quote you
might be more oh reflect the total and
the accurate total in the final bill
they're like wait wait wait we're under
water on the house so if it burns down
we have nothing
what do you mean eight grand i can't
afford that well okay i mean
i guess
service we'll put out half the fire for
half the cost
you know one of our kids is still in
there this this they you can't do that
well uh i am doing that so uh
you've got spare kids obviously sorry
but your home
fire insurance only covers us putting
out one third of the fire
yeah obviously it's naturally selected
that kid should have run
out i mean you've got the smart ones out
here so really what are you worried
about
but but yeah i don't even i can't
imagine what a person would say in that
situation
oh stop don't stop
what kind of monster are you ma'am i'm
not a monster i'm just a businessman i'm
a former amazon scene
ma'am i'm not a monster i'm jeff bezos
speaking of fire have you tried the new
fire tablet available for 199.
if you get a prime subscription you get
free shipping
on all these things you're going to have
to replace firefighter comes down off
the roof covered in ashes and smoke like
ma'am have you checked out season four
of transparent it's an amazon original
series we talked about some
serious real life issues but also about
family issues we can all relate to i
think you should really check it out
consider watching
season four transparent live now on
amazon prime video sometimes if i drop
this person off the roof
what happens if i shut your stupid face
i guess it would no longer be open can
we try
this this roof fire in the back is
literally not going out there must be
something inside
get the the ladder on our truck in a
position where i can
do anything about that did i break this
with a hose
oh i was aiming in the wrong spot the
whole time
are you some kind of [ __ ] sure am there
are so many bodies in this house
this is much more effective when i
actually hit the fire
guys uh guys look at me
hi did you comment oh dear
look at me i'm looking at you
look i know where you are oh look i
am is he on that one god wow
did you hijack the enemy truck now
that's what i just
asked i just asked
hey mark you want to grab the other body
in the living room
sounds like you need to cool off there
bucko
all right fine well why god
am i baby yeah you're in here delivery
service
patient coming in hot nerd fire fighters
over there all right let me
hop out i can't hop out i'm trying to
hop out
hop right out
[Music]
what if you just hit hit e to get out
i'm hitting out
nope not close enough to ground cannot
exit the basket all right hang on
i don't know how much closer to the
ground we're gonna get but i guess we'll
see what we can do
yeah why do we do that when we've got
technology
yeah skadoosh
how did you get into the basket and then
the game's gonna be like no no too high
i don't know man can't get back out i
don't know man
[Music]
you